طبعا هذا الوضع الانساني المتردي في
السودان قد ياخذ البلاد الى ابعد من ذلك
فالصدمات الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه ظواهر
مناخيه قصوى كانت كفيله بعدم صحوه بعض
البلدان من غيبوبه الفقر والانزلاق اكثر
فاكثر الى مستنقع المجاعه ثمانيه عشره
بؤره ساخنه للجوع تضم 22 بلدا مع تنام
منعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد حجما وشده وفق
الامم المتحده افغانستان نيجيريا الصومال
وايضا جنوب السودان واليمن لا تزال في
اعلى درجات التاهب فيما تم رفع مستوى
القلق في هايتي بوركينا فاسو ومالي وحتى
ايضا السودان الى اعلى مستوياته فالمنظمه
الدوليه حذرت من امتداد الازمه في السودان
متوقعه فرار اكثر من مليون شخص وتفشل جوع
الحاد بين نحو مليونين ونصف المليون شخص
داخل السودان في الاشهر المقبله اما اذا
ذهبنا الى
وباكستان وحتى سوريا فتعد ايضا من البؤر
الساخنه التي قد تثير قلقا شديدا ولائحه
اضيف اليها لبنان مؤخرا التقرير داعي الى
اتخاذ اجراءات انسانيه عاجله لمنع حدوث
مجاعه ووفيات في البؤره الساخنه مرجحا
تفاقم الخطر بحلول نوفمبر المقبل اما
المدير العام لمنظمه الاغذيه والزراعه فاو
فاستبعد فعاليه مسارات العمل المعتاده
واكد الحاجه الى تدخلات زراعيه فوريه
حاسمه التوقيت لانقاذ الاشخاص من براثن
الجوع
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات